let's also remember uh
facebook was experimenting on people
yeah we've mentioned this several times
the past week that they
they they were experimenting people
putting depressing information in their
feed to see how they respond and sure
enough people started getting depressed
they would post depressing things the
same thing was true with positive stuff
we know about that
what else do you think they've done you
don't do like i got to tell you i'm i'm
i
when they censor information
it's overt in our face we see it
happening but i have to imagine this
there's a lot of censorship you don't
see at all we know about shadow banning
like we talked about it in the beginning
of the show that people are saying the
link to the to tim castro isn't working
that the notifications aren't going out
and then i'm like well who knows what's
happening then i go to our own website
and our own auto embed feature stopped
working around the exact same time that
so that that's got to be something
there's censorship you can't see but
when it comes to the news feed on
facebook that's where it gets real dark
because that's totally algorithmic
they're choosing what you do see